يبدو انك خيبه الامل الاوكرانيه مشاهدينا
بالحصول على دبابات متطوره دفعها للبحث عن
حل اخر فعلنا تشكيله وحدات عسكريه جديده
مدربه على اسلحه حلف الناتو لدمجها في قوه
الجيش الحاليه فيما نقلت شبكه سي ان عن
مسؤولين العسكريين اوكرانيين قولهم ان
القوات الاوكرانيه تواصل التدريب بالقرب
من الحدود البيلاروسيا استعدادا لربيع
دموي
هذه المنطقه قرب الحدود الفلل الروسيه
واسمها مدينه ليبيات والتي تعرفوا بمدينه
الاشباح حولتها كيف خلال الايام الاخيره
الى قاعده تدريب لقواتها المدينه التي تقع
شماليه البلاد هجرها سكانها بعد كارثه
تشيرنوبل حيث كانت المدينه مهيئه انا ذات
للمفاعل النووي واليوم تستغل اوكرانيا
تضاريسها المتنوعه لتدريب القوات عن
مختلفه الظروف
ان المدينه استفاده من وضعها صناع المسلسل
الشهير شنو نوبل لتصوير حلقات من المسلسل
هناك كما قام فريقه عمل لعبه كول اوف
ديوتي فور بتصوير المدينه في هذه اللعبه
[موسيقى]
في موازنه ذلك كشفت واشنطن منذ ايام
تدريباتها للقوات الاوكرانيه على انواع
المختلفه من الاسلحه وكان قائد واركان
المشتركه
تحدث عن ان البرنامج التدريبي للقوات
الاوكرانيه سيكون اكثر توسعا وتعقيدا
وسيتواصل لفتره بين خمسه وثمانيه اسابيع